[Music]
how Speaker Nancy Pelosi has unveiled
the Democrats proposal for another covet
19 relief package this one is nearly
three trillion dollars and it's eighteen
hundred pages long as Sean mentioned
earlier and guess what the house is
expected to return to Washington this
Friday and vote on it that's right
Friday giving lawmakers less than a week
to make a decision with taxpayer dollars
that's your money the bill is expected
to include one trillion dollars for
state and local governments and that is
roughly double Congress's spending so
far it would also send another round of
direct checks to Americans this time it
would deliver 1200 for individuals 2,400
for married couples and 1200 for each
dependent up to maximum of 3 the House
bill would also extend additional $600 a
week and enhanced unemployment benefits
which is supposed to be expired in July
it would be extended now through January
and the bill would expand stimulus
payments to previous groups that were
excluded dependents over the age of 16
and some individuals who don't have a
Social Security number meanwhile
Democrats in both the House and the
Senate have rejected talks offering
additional legal protection to
businesses and top Senate Republicans
say the proposal is dead on arrival call
it an empty unrealistic publicity stunt
well we lot to talk about so here is our
company host of the michael knowles show
michael knowles and senior policy
director at the conservative partnership
institute and republican strategist
rachel brevard the hero for being here
thank you thank you all right guys this
bill as Lindsay and I have mentioned is
1,800 pages and I noted earlier that if
you read this a minute a page it's gonna
take you 30 hours so it's pretty obvious
that no one's gonna read it we've seen
what's happened in the previous bills
the Democrats are now saying that this
is a messaging bill what message is this
sending look I want to take care of
people I'm sure you want to take people
take care of people there's a lot of
people that are hurting both
economically in a lot of cases
health-wise I don't get this one of the
things that was listed in there is make
sure you don't need a social security
number anymore to get help what message
are the Democrats trying to send because
I don't think this is compassion this is
stupidity Michael I think you hit the
nail on the head
this is a messaging bill it's not so
much a spending bill as it is a
fundraising letter they're trying to
send a message Nancy Pelosi is trying to
speak to Democrats around the country
and get them to raise money for
Democratic candidates because they
resent a wish list to them of left-wing
proposals of bailing out bad left-wing
governance in states like California and
New York and it's it's just not going to
happen it is dead on arrival it's not a
serious proposal and the one downside of
this message I think for Democrats is it
reminds us that the only way that we're
actually going to be able to recover to
put food on people's tables to put money
in people's pockets is to reopen the
economy and we can do that carefully and
we can do it slowly but that's the only
way there's there's no amount of federal
spending that's going to fix this
problem for us yeah when you look at the
last time that we passed a bill had a
lot of pork in it you think if the
Kennedy Center Harvard roost Chris all
these things that were coming out these
people's pet projects and so Rachel my
question to you is how do we make sure
that doesn't happen again who is
analyzing this to say hey these things
are in there when it's 1,800 pages long
and you only have a few days to review
it can we be know that there there
aren't these pork things in there we
can't and I think one of the interesting
things about how we got here is remember
the house is not in session the members
are far-flung all over the country so
who's writing this bill it's not the
members it's the staff and so they're
basically putting in all this work
hoping no one notices and this is why we
ended up with provisions for banking for
the marijuana industry
more grants for the National Endowment
for the art in addition to a host of
other things like a biohazards for
animals and wildlife like all of these
things that have absolutely nothing to
do with the targeted and temporary
relief that Americans need and so I
think you know Senate Republicans are
right to say this is dead on arrival
it's completely unserious but it also
should trouble us because this these are
Democrat priorities this is what they
want they want to fundamentally
transform how we do elections in this
country you have amnesty the thousands
and millions of illegal immigrants all
of that is in this bill so this is a
playbook for how they're gonna go
forward yeah I think you're absolutely
right that the idea that they're not
here no one they're gonna get jammed on
this no one's gonna read it and then
we're gonna be spending the next three
or four weeks trying to thing
how we got ourselves into a mess with a
bunch of people one of the things
Michael that's apparently tucked in the
Bell and I can't say that it is or isn't
because I haven't read it like anyone
else but they talk about bailing out
local media organizations because
remember the issue that happen with a
lot of these companies because they are
subsidiaries that they didn't qualify so
a local you know organization that was
part of a bigger company didn't and
because a lot of media organizations are
part of bigger organizations they didn't
qualify now they're being told that
they're gonna help out do you think that
this is the appropriate way to take care
of the media it's it's endless I mean we
think that the media in this country are
too cozy with politicians to begin with
this probably isn't going to help their
reputation this was a bit of a problem
in the initial stimulus bill and the
recovery bill is that these smaller
organizations that were tied to larger
ones couldn't get funding but an
additional three trillion dollar
spending package isn't going to do that
it's politically going to look
disastrous speaking of the messages the
Democrats are trying to spend but but it
also simply won't work there isn't
enough money the money printing machine
does not work well enough to to bias
three more months as the mayor of LA
wants or six months or two years or
whoever knows what they want the way to
get the media to first of all the way to
get the media working is for them to
have more credibility than they
currently do and the way to get the rest
of the economy going is to open up and
get working again right rich will only
have one minute left but aren't we going
about this the wrong way it's almost
like we're saying here's a check to
these states do whatever you want with
it instead of saying give us an itemized
list so we can see what you need and how
you're gonna spin it and giving some
responsibility to them saying you can't
just have it open blank check
essentially yeah the accountability for
how these funds are spent is something
that's completely missing from all of
these proposals but it's a key feature
you know every state looks different
every States needs are different some
states have been very responsible in
this regard in some states if not and
yet the ones who are not are turning to
the American taxpayers and saying you
know bail us out help us with our
underfunded pension liabilities things
that have nothing to do again with
addressing the needs from the
coronavirus crisis so a lot more
prudence a lot more thoughtfulness and
just plain reading the bill is needed I
think before we can move forward
any of this I think you're exactly right
thank you both for your input and
breaking this all down with us thank you
thank you